justin trudeau vise encore et toujours
la classe moyenne mais son approche est
différente c'est le premier en 2015
on a continué de démontrer qu'une
société confiant dans son avenir et v6
dans cet avenir et c'est le contraste
faut que les gens vont faire face les
libéraux promettent 48 nouvelles mesures
qui coûteront au total près de 57
milliards de dollars au cours des quatre
prochaines années
15 milliards en baisses d'impôts 9
milliards pour bonifier la sécurité de
la vieillesse 6 milliards pour la santé
4 milliards pour augmenter l'allocation
canadienne pour enfants et près de 3
milliards pour les étudiants mais on
reconnaît qu avec tout l'aide qu'on a
fait il ya encore des gens qui ont
besoin de plus d'argent c'est pour ça
qu'on va continuer d'investir dans nos
communautés pour financer une partie de
ces nouvelles dépenses
les libéraux promettent d'aller chercher
de nouveaux revenus en allant le
chercher plus d'argent chez les mieux
nantis en fermant des échappatoires
fiscaux il promet aussi de taxer les
géants du web
contrairement à son engagement en 2015
avec l'arrivée de plus en plus deux
géants mondiaux multinationales comme
désigné et autres qui vont commencer à
frère du streaming au canada et c'est
important d'assurer que à des compagnies
canadiennes puissent plus bénéficier des
mêmes avantages que les compagnies
internationaux autre changement
important
les libéraux n'ont cette fois ci aucun
plan pour revenir à l'équilibré
budgétaire
justin trudeau se contente de dire que
le ratio dette pib du canada est le plus
bas des pays du g7 défaitisme en
responsables de nos communautés
c'est ce qui a contribué à la croissance
économique au bénéfice pour les
individus et à une stabilité économique
et sociale
les libéraux font le pari que les
canadiens sont prêts à accepter
plusieurs autres années de déficits
s'ils reçoivent plus de services et des
baisses d'impôts ils veulent ainsi
dépeindre leurs adversaires
conservateurs comme le parti de
l'austérité qui voudra à tout prix
réquilibrer le budget en 5 1
il s'y fait le bain sans point et radio
canada mais ces sagas